Speaker 1: Well, last week it was Lindsey Graham
who was told you are going to have to respond
to the subpoena and testify in the Georgia probe
of the election fraud attempt by Donald Trump in
2020. And now Donald Trump's former lawyer, Rudy
Giuliani, has been told the exact same thing the
Associated Press is now reporting Giuliani ordered
to testify in Georgia 2020 election probe. This is
not the news that Rudy Giuliani wanted. Now, a
few important things to mention here. First and
foremost, as a reminder, this is the probe
in Georgia. There is a grand jury. This is
separate from the January six committee. They are
looking into Trump and associates attempt to take
Georgia's electoral votes from Joe Biden even
though Joe Biden. This includes Trump calling
and saying, I need 11,000 votes. Gimme a break. It
includes Lindsey Graham calling and saying, well,
can't we look into what could be done now?
As of right now, the last we heard, Lindsey
Graham and Rudy Giuliani received subpoenas.
But they are not targets. They are considered
witnesses. The way Rudy operates, he could make
himself a target by showing up and unknowingly
implicating himself and others. That wouldn't
come as a huge shock. But at least for now,
Lindsey Graham's attempt to get out of testifying
has been shut down by a judge. And Rudy's as well.
The AP says a judge in New York has ordered Rudy
Giuliani to appear next month before a special
grand jury in Atlanta investigating whether former
President Trump and others illegally tried to
interfere in the 2020 election in Georgia. New
York Supreme Court Justice Thomas Farber issued
an order directing Giuliani to appear before
the special grand jury August 9th and any
other dates ordered by the court. Giuliani's
lawyer did not immediately return a call.
Fulton County District Attorney Fanny Willis
began her investigation early last year.
Earlier this month, she filed petitions to
compel seven Trump associates, including
Giuliani and Lindsey Graham, to testify because
they don't live in Georgia. She used a process
that involves getting a judge in a state where
they live to order them to appear. Now, here's an
interesting detail. Giuliani had been summoned to
appear in court in New York on July 13 to present
any reason why a subpoena should not be issued
for him to testify in Atlanta. But he failed
to show up for that hearing. In a court filing
Wednesday, Willis informed the judge overseeing
the grand jury. Giuliani had been served with
the final order instructing him to appear.
It's possible Giuliani could file a motion with
the court in Atlanta to try to avoid testifying.
Others have already filed challenges to try to get
out of that. This is actually the second time that
the same Manhattan judge ordered Rudy Giuliani to
testify in the Georgia grand jury. He was given
a date previously to appear and he didn't go. And
now he's being told again to go on August 9th. So
if you said to me, David, you've got a bet, sir.
No odds, just straight up. Do you bet that Graham
and Giuliani testify or do you bet that they
don't? I don't know which bet I take right now. It
feels very 5050. If you were me, if you or I were
refusing to testify, refusing to appear before a
grand jury, after being subpoenaed, especially
when a judge writes, you've got to be there,
we'd be in a jail cell awaiting trial on contempt
charges, I presume. But here we're talking about
Lindsey Graham. Here we're talking about Rudy
Giuliani and. What's going to happen? I really
don't know. The relationship between this
investigation and the January six committee.
It involves a lot of the same people, but
these are two separate investigations. And
I continue to believe that if there will
be charges levied against Donald Trump,
they will come out of the Georgia
probe, not out of the January six
committee. But I would love it for
charges to come out of all of them.